it's a HDD Bay cover and now we will  prepare nine color variations to be sold  separately this product will be  available only in sony stores in prior  to launch on november six the seven  colors excluding gold and silver will be  available for pre-ordering starting  today at 6pm and sony stores as an  addition to the lineup we will have  crystal color for sales a limited number  of gold silver and still black will be  available on november sixth and  additional line up crystal color on  December third this one hands the  realistic and dynamic of the game the  wire around headset will be available  domestically this will also be available  on December turn